this interesting thing that I think
Twitter is doing but I know Facebook is
doing for sure which is
really interesting so you have what are
the signals that a human can provide at
scale like in Twitter's retweet
um in Facebook I think you can share I
think yeah but there's basic
interactions you can have comment and so
on yeah but there's also in Facebook and
YouTube has this too is um
would you like to see more of this or
would you like to see less of this they
post that sometimes and the thing that
the the neural net that's learning from
that has to figure out is the intent
behind you saying I want to see less of
this did you see too much of this
content already uh you like it but you
don't want to see so much of it uh you
already figured it out good great or
does this content not make you feel good
there's so many interpretations that I'd
like to see all of this but if you get
that kind of signal this actually can
create a really
um
powerfully curated
uh list of content that is fed to you
every day that doesn't it doesn't create
an echo chamber or Silo it actually just
makes you feel good yeah in the in the
good way which is like it challenges you
but it doesn't exhaust you and make you
kind of this this is this weird animal
I've been saying for a long time if I
went on Facebook one morning
and they said oh we're testing a new
option
rather than showing you things we think
you're going to like we want to show you
some things that we think you will
disagree with but which we have some
signals that suggest it's of quality
like now that sounds interesting yeah
that sounds really interesting I want to
see something where you know like oh I
don't I don't agree with so uh Larry
lessig is a good friend of mine founder
of Creative Commons and he's moved on to
doing stuff about corruption and
politics and so on and I don't always
agree with Larry but I always grapple
with Larry because he's so interesting
and he's so thoughtful that even when we
don't agree I'm like actually I want to
hear him out right because I'm going to
learn from it and that doesn't mean I
always come around to agreeing with him
but I'm going to understand a
perspective and that's really a great
feeling yeah there's this interesting
thing on social media where people kind
of accuse others of saying well you
don't want to hear opinions that you
disagree with their ideas you disagree
with I think this is something that's
thrown in me all the time the reality is
there's literally almost nothing I enjoy
more
odd thing to accuse you of because if
you have quite a wide range of long
conversations with a very diverse bunch
of people but there is a very
there is like a a very harsh drop off
because what I like is high quality
disagreement that really makes you think
yeah and at a certain point there's a
threshold it's kind of a gray area when
the quality of the disagreement it just
sounds like mocking you're not really
interested in uh a deep understanding of
the topic or you yourself don't seem to
carry deep understanding of the topic
like uh there's something called uh
intelligent Square debates yeah the main
one is the British version with the
British accent everything always sounds
better and the Brits seem to argue more
intensely like their uh invigorated
they're energized by the debate those
people I often disagree with basically
everybody involved and it's so fun I
learned something that's high quality if
we could do that if there's some way for
me to click a button that says
um
filter all lower quality just today you
sometimes show it to me because I want
to be able to but today I'm just not in
the mood for the mockery yeah just high
quality stuff even because even flatter
I wanna I wanna get high quality
Arguments for the Flat Earth it would
make me feel good because I'll see oh
that's really interesting like I never
really
thought in my mind to challenge the
mainstream Narrative of uh
uh of general relativity right of uh of
a perception of physics maybe all of
reality maybe all of all of space-time
is an illusion
that's really interesting I never really
thought about let me consider that fully
okay what's the evidence how do you test
that what is uh what are the
Alternatives how would you be uh able to
have such consistent perception of a
physical reality if it's all of it is an
illusion uh all of us seem to share the
same kind of perceptional reality like
what like that's the kind of stuff I
love but not like the mockery of it you
know that uh the the cheap that it seems
that uh social media can kind of inspire